so as far as video game movies go hmm
Assassin's Creed was bad in in new and
surprising ways I wasn't really expected
it's like I was okay I was expecting it
to be bad um but I was expecting it to
just kind of be you know a little bit
cheesy a little bit incoherent a little
bit a little bit just you know just
generically not good I was not expecting
what we actually got though which is
something that was highly highly
incoherent and just the it's a late
contender for worst editing of the year
I think Suicide Squad is still going to
get that because of bigger bigger issues
with Suicide Squad that Suicide Squad
managed to be both have moment-to-moment
poor editing as well as scene to scene
poor editing just you know big
structural deep structural problems with
with Suicide Squad this you know it
looks and for the most part it looks and
flows kind of just like a normal
ordinary run-of-the-mill action movie
the so the first five Assassin's Creed
games or at least the mainline
Assassin's Creed games all have you in
the role of the protagonist Desmond
Miles and sorry okay the conceit of
Assassin's Creed is that you've got a
character who is being sent back to
experience the lives of their ancestors
through DNA genetic memory it's it's
total just BS garbage whoo and I love it
it's it's so stupid and in that regard
Assassin's Creed has a lot of dumb stuff
has a lot of dumb stuff in it and for
the most part they managed to capture a
lot of that unfortunately they didn't
capture enough
of the fun they went a lot with the very
self serious elements of Assassin's
Creed and so what you end up with is uh
I don't remember
the protagonists name Cal maybe it was
Cal like Calvin um but so the first the
first five Assassin's Creed games your
real world protagonist is Desmond Miles
and then he goes into he goes back and
experiences the lives of his ancestors
uh
Ezio altai year and Connor and you get
three games with Ezio and one with each
of the others and but Desmond Desmond in
and of himself has become a little bit
legendary for being a completely just
utterly uninteresting protagonist like
he has barely any character traits which
in the context of the games I'm not
going to say it's forgivable but it kind
of makes sense in terms of your
narrative economy where you're going to
want to be focusing on you know the
character that you actually spend most
of the time with most of the game with
which would be the the ancestor so you
spend a lot more time learning kind of
who all ty here is you spend a lot more
time learning who who Ezio is and you
know that's where just kind of the
writing energy goes that's not to say
that you can't make Desmond compelling
it's just that if you had to pick which
of those two is going to be boring you
know if you were forced to pick if you
know if you're going to make a bad
writing decision it's it's the least
damaging of the two because you spend
way more time with the ancestor than you
do with the real-world counterpart so
the problem that they ran into here is
that they didn't make either of them
interesting I think they understood the
problem there that it's like okay it
takes a lot of
time to really well and truly introduce
the audience to two protagonists like if
especially if they're not really
interacting with one another if they
exist in completely different storylines
so they focused a bit more on kal than
on his ancestor whose name was how his
name was not how that was just me that
was how Amy what are you doing you're
getting nippy right now so they spent a
lot more time focusing on Calvin on his
ancestor but the the byproduct of that
is that they still weren't able to make
Cal interesting we don't really know
much of anything about him he killed
someone like the movie starts off or I
guess the main the main plot starts off
with uh Cal being executed for murder
like he's on death row and it's like his
last day so he goes through it like he
gets last rites and then goes and gets a
lethal injection and that's kind of
that's your introduction to him as an
adult because there's one scene with him
as a kid
and after that like you you don't really
learn more about him after that it's
just kind of it um there's there's
little bits here and there like he gets
to confront his dad who murdered his mom
and you learned that she actually kind
of murdered herself or got him to do it
because because Abstergo alright alright
so the they kept this intact because
this this is the absurdity that I love
so Abstergo is looking for an artifact
called the apple of Eden which they're
going to use to basically mind-control
the entire world
and they're trying to figure out where
it's being hidden and so and this is
this is lifted right out of the games
like this is what they spend the first
several games trying to do is track down
this artifact and and so they're going
through basically persons ancestors to
be like hey we're following its path and
we're trying to figure out where where
it got lost where it's sitting right now
and then we'll go get it and uh because
the ancestor is actually through Cal's
mother's line she killed herself got dad
to kill her in order to keep the apple
of Eden safe so that Abstergo couldn't
stick her into the Animas machine that
lets them look at the lives of your
ancestors um and you know it's it's
ridiculous garbage and I love that
aspect of it but the the bad parts are
is that you really don't get to know any
of these characters so they're they're
kind of meaningless to you Michael
Fassbender as Cal is just completely
checked out he's got almost no dialogue
he just kind of like sneers and looks at
stuff and you only get kind of a vague
sense of what his motivations are even
supposed to be and then he has a sudden
change of heart for really vague reasons
that just kind of have to do with his
mom or have to do with him with his
ancestor lose like a woman dies I don't
know her name but she dies as she was
clearly like she was clearly the
ancestor is like you know his sidepiece
or something and she dies and it's all
sad if you could bring yourself to care
about any of these characters and that
is apparently what gives Cal his change
of heart and then he decides
to help the assassins instead of instead
of destroying them because he uh he
starts off not helping Abstergo but that
is like okay I guess I'll help them stir
go and and and then he changes his mind
but then it gets even weirder
okay so Marion Cotillard is in this and
she's she's the sort of replacement for
Desmond's fish-faced girlfriend who was
an obscure go employee who had a change
of heart except in this case she's the
daughter of the CEO of Abstergo that's
run by the Templars and and if all of
this just kind of sounds like complete
nonsense yeah yeah it is
and I kind of love it but in this case
it's rapidly becoming quite frustrating
and okay so Marion Cotillard spends most
of the movie telling kal that she's
going to cure aggression they're going
to track down the Apple and is going to
give them the the cure to aggression and
to negative emotions and violence and
all of this and then at the very end
okay so Abstergo managed is finding the
apple it's in Christopher Columbus's
grave and they get it and then they're
at their big celebration party where all
of the evil people in the world are
gathered in one place to be like ah ha
ha
we're so evil and we're gonna run
everything now and she has this fight
with her dad that makes no sense
whatsoever because she's just like this
is too far I can't believe you're going
to do this and he's like we're going to
destroy free will no one in the world
will have free will anymore and she's
like that's too far and it's just like
girl what did you think you were doing
like were you
on the same page as everyone else and so
she kind of gives them this this weird
ultimatum that doesn't make any sense
like she has like it's not just that she
has a change of heart she doesn't
because she doesn't have it to change
there isn't really a moment the clothes
that indicates that she has changed her
opinion about what they're doing because
she's not saying like hey actually I
thought about it and this is a bad idea
she's basically accusing him of lying to
her like she had other goals all along
and he's like I always knew you were
more committed to science than to the
Templars and it's like what like would
she's her goal is to like mind control
the entire world like how is she not how
is she not down with this and so this
whole you know you lied to me kind of
sort of kind of take on it it's just I
don't know I don't I don't know what is
going on and then and then the best part
is that shortly after that the movie
just kind of ends it it doesn't really
have an ending it doesn't have a non
ending either it just ends um you know
movies that have non endings you know if
you want to talk like No Country for Old
Men as a basically has a non ending
that's my collarbone that's my
collarbone she she wants attention um
all right all right all right so it
doesn't really have a note it doesn't
even have a non ending it just ends the
the assassins storm evil headquarters
steal the Apple back and then all of a
sudden okay this this is weird and it's
I'm going to need to explain kind of
what's happening okay so when you're
talking about like figuring out who the
protagonist of a movie is it it
ultimately comes down to the way that
the camera behaves towards the character
orbit or towards the various characters
like the weight that it gives them the
choice of where the edits are made or
like or who the edits bias towards so if
we spend if if something critical
happens and we cut to a character's face
that kind of decision made over a period
of time like you know made consistently
is what is going to really communicate
to the audience who the important
characters are who are the ones that
they should be paying attention to who
are the ones that they should be
emotionally invested in who's the
protagonist who's the main character and
so you end up at the very end where this
climax happens and they kill Jeremy
Irons and they steal the Apple back and
then it spends the resolution of that
sequence following Marion Cotillard
around
rather than the assassins so it's a
switch it we basically and she's the one
who gets the response monologue and her
inner sort of response monologue is is
not villainous I don't even remember the
content of it anymore
I remember the emotional tone of it
though
I don't remember what she actually says
we're like kind of wet
she sort of thinks about all of this but
she's just her her response was not like
oh I'll get you you rascally rabbit it
was it was just kind of like well I
guess this is the future of the hue and
of Terminator 2 kind of kind of
situation it was just strange to
suddenly have this like alright are our
emotional center our protagonist is
suddenly switching to Marion Cotillard
character and then it goes out to
Michael Fassbender and he's just
standing on a tower looking what someone
at Ubisoft thinks his badass and he
holds the Apple and credits roll and see
there's a point where sequel mate like
so there's a phrase that a lot of people
like to use sequel bait where you're
clearly putting in things at the end of
your movie that are leading to a sequel
it's basically a some form of Jeopardy
or some stakes that need to be resolved
next and it has varying degrees of
success but the problem is is that if
you put too many of those in you're not
really it's not sequel bit anymore
you're setting up the next scene you're
setting up the next sequence you're
setting up the next
of the movie and so this movie doesn't
have a third act because right around
the point that it's kind of getting to
be like okay structurally it is a
complete and coherent mess because the
emotional the your emotional connection
to the characters in the movie switch at
the last minute from Michael
Fassbender's non character who is not
emotionally relatable at all to Marion
Cotillard except she's one of the
antagonists and she has this change of
heart but her change of heart isn't
really a change of sides because she
doesn't begin to assist them and she she
just becomes the new person that we care
about and her goals become the ones that
we care about and so at the last minute
they bait-and-switch that oh she's the
main character now and we care about her
and they have stolen from her and so
clearly we're going to follow her into
the final confrontation where all of
this is going to get sorted out and it
doesn't happen there is there is no
scene there it just it does not happen
there's no resolution to it and it goes
so far beyond just being sequel bait
that it's like there's another scene
that this script needs and it's not
there oh jeez what else okay so the the
action in this and this goes to I think
some of the reasons why I said that it
was a late contender for some of the
worst editing of the year is the action
scenes are completely incomprehensible
they're almost impossible to follow
though it's the fault of both the editor
and the cinematographer none of the
action scenes are shot in any sort of
wide and it never holds on the
wider medium long enough to figure out
where people are in relation to one
another where they're going where they
need to get to where they've come from
so the spatial relationships are just
complete garbage and the action scenes
are shot entirely in really really tight
fast swinging close-ups I've just spent
the last couple days spending a lot of
time looking at Batman vs Superman in
super slow motion like frame by frame
because I needed to do a bunch of
editing analysis and I was busy putting
a bunch of like tracking marks on things
and it it really started to stand out to
me just how often any given frame of
Batman versus Superman is just a
complete mush of a blur
and this was even worse
this was just way way worse the whole
thing is in these like ultra tight
close-ups like frequently you know
you're looking at a framing like this or
just you know basically just a hand
and now those kinds of shots those kinds
of of punctuation shots are not a bad
thing but they are exactly what they
sound like they're punctuation shots you
use them to drive home a point or to
communicate a sequence like they they
end is something uh if you build a
sentence entirely out of punctuation it
stops meaning anything it doesn't mean
anything anymore
it's just a bunch of symbols and that's
what the action looks like in this is
it's nothing but these ultra tight
close-ups and then 1/2 second at most a
quarter to a half second of some sort of
like cowboy not even a wide like a
cowboy shot of someone like jumping out
of a window and then it goes to like an
ultra tight of them like landing and so
the movement from place to place is just
kind of a general flow and it works but
the actual like okay a bunch of people
are in a room fighting each other that
room doesn't look like anything like
it's it's almost impossible to tell what
that room looks like is anyone else in
the room is why this room where are they
trying to go have like what are the
stakes if you can't read the scenario
you can't read the stakes and that
brings me to another point and this goes
to the scriptwriter
when you're dealing with flashbacks or
things that happened before the present
the threat of death is poor jeopardy to
use they're constantly trying to build
drama to build jeopardy by using oh is I
really wish I could remember that
character's name you know is the
ancestor dude is this dude gonna die
like he's in this life-threatening
situation is this gonna be it for a
minutes like no it's it's clearly not we
we explicitly by the conceits of the
fiction know that it is not and so there
there is no drama if if the only drama
if the only beat for the drama is will
he die it's not enough um you know you
can threaten the lives of other
characters you can threaten to take away
something that's important to them you
can delay them you can you know there's
a lot of different ways that you can add
jeopardy to the scenario so why use the
only one that doesn't work there's a lot
of other just minor absurdities through
it but I think I think that is a good
indication of kind of what you're gonna
get out of this and if it's it's a
watchable bad movie it's a very
learnable bad movie like there's a lot
of lessons that you can kind of take
from the many many poor poor choices
that are made that are made in this
movie so you can learn a lot from
picking a part kind of where where it
goes wrong why it goes wrong what its
feelings are and so in that regard like
yeah it might be watchable it's if
you're gonna put on a video game movie
like with a group of friends that you
can just like make fun of like clearly
the
the correct answer is still Street
Fighter um or Legend of chun-li but this
one it is it is a it's a good addition
it's a good bad addition to the the
Canon of awful video game movies Frick
she got me good Oh